hey 42 here in 1978 paleoanthropologist
Andrew Hill was throwing [ __ ] at his
colleague when he discovered one of the
most important pieces of evidence to
ever support the theory of evolution
he'll and his colleague were avoiding
doing any real work by throwing elephant
dung 'but one another at an
archaeological site in tanzania he doped
towards the ground to narrowly avoid a
large doomed projectile hitting him in
the face as he slammed into the ground
he noticed something something peculiar
within the dirt of the excavation site a
trail of footprints these incredible
footprints that have been perfectly
preserved by hardened volcanic ash were
found to be 3.6 million years old they
had been made by some of the very first
upright walking hominids up until Hills
chance discovery the oldest human
footprints we had found were only tens
of thousands of years old 3.6 million
years ago when these footprints were
made our ancestors looked remarkably
similar yet so very very different than
modern man
Australopithecus is the name that
science has given to the specimens found
from this period of humans evolutionary
timeline
Australopithecus looks profoundly more
ape-like compared to modern-day humans
they had far smaller brains a protruding
large jaw and stubby noses the progress
mankind has made physically in what is
relatively a very small amount of time
it's mind-blowing if evolution carried
on it literate I should have superpowers
in no time
where's my x-ray vision and superior
Hunslet whoops along the way something's
happened and evolution was stopped in
its tracks human evolution has
progressed so remarkably fast earth is
4.5 billion years old and in only a tiny
7 million years which equates to just
0.15 percent of a fish
humans have evolved from a primitive
ape-like ancestor to a walking talking
intelligent beings well most of us
anyway
but this rapid physical and mental
change in our species was caused due to
immense environmental pressure for the
vast majority of mankind's history and
our ancestors history we have not been
predators like we are today for prey
only with the advent of weapons and
technological advancements have we risen
to the top of the food chain
many early fossilized human remains have
been found all over the globe that have
fatal wounds made by animals such as
tigers leopards and even by an eagle's
talons as was found to be the cause of
death of the two million year old
tongues child so both physical and
mental adaptation was necessary for our
species teacher survival and prosperity
rapid changes had to be made so we were
better equipped both mentally and
physically to fend off predators and
find food and so evolution showed no
signs of stopping but then we went and
ruined it all by saying something stupid
like let's build a homogeneous
civilization in 3100 BC Mesopotamia was
built the first human civilization
huge advances were made in farming and
humans no longer needed to forage or
hunt to survive after centuries have
passed we have on average all become
wealthier better medicated and gained
easier access to food the pressure to
adapt to our environment disappeared and
so did the rapid evolutionary progress
today not only the fittest and strongest
pass on their genes to the next
generation of everybody does this is
especially true in the West with modern
medicine and food at our fingertips
whenever we desire it even the most
stupid and weakest members of society
will pass on their genes and that they
most certainly do
even if said individuals don't know
exactly
Jeanne's they have passed on what only
needs to watch five minutes of Joe
McHale to understand what I'm talking
about
so in developed countries at least there
is no natural selection anymore so David
Attenborough himself said that we are
the only species to have put a halt to
natural selection of its own free will
awesome Berg predicts that physical
evolution in humans will eventually
cease completely and we will instead go
through a process of cultural evolution
in which we will evolve mentally so well
survival of the fittest may no longer
hold true survival of the intelligent
certainly does as each generation builds
upon the wisdom of those before them
intellectual growth will speed up
exponentially today a person survival
depends not on whether they can
effectively hunt prey but whether they
can secure a good job to buy food for
themselves and their family it has thus
become more important than ever that
people are more intelligent and more
creative than their peers realistically
there are only so many jobs in the world
and this fierce competition to be the
best climb the ladder and steal more
prestigious jobs from others has put an
evolutionary pressure on our minds the
Flynn effect is the observation not
overtime average IQ levels have
increased substantially since 1904 when
IQ tests were first used the average IQ
level across the globe has increased
every single year in a linear fashion
every few years
IQ tests are completely rewritten and
intentionally made harder so that the
global average always remains at 100
what if you were to take an IQ test from
80 years ago you would find it
significantly easier than a modern-day
test human evolution has not stopped far
from it but its goals have changed
mental acuity is now the next target of
natural selection
so it looks like that x-ray vision might
have to wait shame so we're evolving
culturally they'll low that's very hard
to believe looking at the current state
of contemporary music but what's about
physically is this really all we're
getting has humanity peaked
aesthetically and mechanically well that
may not be entirely the case it's
generally accepted that evolution has
been slowing down since the dawn of
human civilization but we shouldn't be
so quick to put a definite end on
physical evolution after all mutations
don't occur overnight
they take tens of thousands sometimes
hundreds of thousands of years to take
wholes and if we look really closely at
recent history we have actually changed
physically in recent times despite
getting more intelligence over the past
thirty thousand years our brains have
shrunk from an average of 1500 cubic
centimeters to 1,350 cubic centimeters
blue eyes are a prime example of
evolution until just 10,000 years ago
blue eyes did not exist everyone had
brown eyes what 10,000 years ago some
unknown patient zero near the Black Sea
developed a genetic mutation that turned
their eyes blue they passed down the
blue-eyed mutation to many of us and
very soon blue eyes became extremely
popular so an unexpected reason blue
eyes were an early form of paternity
test men would often prefer female
partners who had blue eyes because the
man would know that if his wife had a
blue-eyed baby then it was probably his
if the baby had brown eyes then someone
had been a little bit more tea studies
have shown that most men find blue eyes
more attractive than brown and it's
thought that this unreliable historical
paternity test could be the reason why
of course we now know that the genes
which determine eye color can be passed
down through several family generations
and even if both parents have blue
it's still possible for them to give
birth to a brown-eyed baby so I imagine
throughout history a lot of unlucky
women were incorrectly accused of
cheating but surely one of the best ways
we have evolved in modern times is that
humans have become naturally more
resistant to diseases even when we have
food on the table and good healthcare
there is one environmental pressure that
hasn't left us alone since the dawn of
time disease and one of the world's
biggest diseases and biggest killers is
malaria over 1 million people die for
malaria each year mostly in sub-saharan
Africa but in 2007 a study found a group
of 1,800 previously undiscovered genes
that have only become prevalent in
humans in the past 40,000 years these
genes make us more resistant to various
diseases such as tuberculosis leprosy
and even malaria and it's predicted that
these genes will only become stronger
and more prevalent within this human
race in the future evolution has
conquered hunger and within the next few
hundred millennia we may have even
conquered disease for good thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon which helps out the tunnel and
you can get some cool rewards like early
access to all my videos click here to
watch another video and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe